The government takes advantage of the situation,
a country full of crime is all we can do,
because now I
think that they are more crooks than
the crooks themselves, we had
this government of female authors, that
and also with serious accusations
against it
[Music]
in worrisome
in the missions and the order is given that
commander chávez left is to defend the
revolutionary process no matter what it costs us
the revolution for us died when
commander char died
[Music]
note longa that when hugo chávez
hostile or live venezuela client of
locate socialism
the visitors excess nicolás mature
it's on the brink state failed
individual and you don't understand venezuela
enjoy the one of latin america college
by captain cannes
pico 77 are the world's largest forget
the two girls saudi
venezuela from venezuela that suffers this
outgoing rock cyclone
revolution
economic cross professional criminal
allegation sweeting of isolated
fire s  in cristo
lady life for the media bowl i
saw volcano fine food and ben affleck
in all day
[Music]
we are seeing with sadness that the dream
that one day we supported and no longer
exists is
no longer a
reality food has been  as a
new added value more suffering
because I know we talked about how they
completely destroyed our lives
with their team we
have to get
mango
francisco
late
ah
miracle
for us this is gold one month I had
to not get paid today I was lucky
we got bread for the children
at school children eat
family that works together stays
together
we are revolutionaries deep down
because we believe that
society has to have a change
that will not see so much misery and so much poverty
we believed in the Bolivarian revolution
and we support it but we see that the revolution
It is not what was raised at that time
because Commander Chavez
provided the resources and achieved improvements
in the communities.  from low-income
now that poverty has multiplied
corruption has multiplied and for
us the aggravating factor is that the
military that are in power today
have mafias that control all the
missions left by president chávez
carlos story kate gusto
[Music]
el  The day they arrived they only
told us that it was a presidential order
that we had to vacate the
sector and that we had to leave there
as they did not care when in two
hours maximum how by our
own means this where he slept was
where we were going to be that  their order did not matter to them, it
was to comply with a
presidential order and they were going to execute him
at any cost
[Music
] whoever did not want a way out by hook
or by crook
if it is serious the initial testimonies
the parties delicately plus sucre the
first
and sell carlos leeb and nevis fulbright
you know community
[Music]
and
the longing
is complete it is about voting for the future of
venezuela from v  Opting for the new path
that we have to open for our children
to our descendants is about going
to build each one with their grain of
sand to build this new Venezuela
that we are starting already he was scholes
and project deep silver solution for
missing project family by  carlos is
attribution of chávez this christmas and
your place invernales that again
illusions brolin dental problems of the
international jean the price is the sun
collapse
venezuela they are oaks or accelerated àngel
mature
you want to leave it I have left the same
hyperinflation
prowse my hands give me an
exhaustive review of the  football
the blocks
[Music]
like that gasworks classes in phrases with Maduro
present
[Music]
the situation got worse because Maduro
we have much less control than
Chávez himself had
the economic policy that I had right now
is an economic policy that favors
a small fraction of the population and
harms all the rest
will have to be the mafia state in
state m  It's ridiculous that we have a
political village with a child, it's absurd, there
has to be a change
from politics to economics to
solve these things, this is no longer
just unsustainable if you didn't think
portal
press in the sense of sant benet balance
wants mature out
andrew lim show
venezuela is in  peace today all of venezuela
producing working
caracas until now is in absolute peace
tranquility
of carmen world news of opposition
dominates elements and beats more than 28 suspend
mature olive qtrax peaks so domestic
and international apprehension
court of control is the largest
institution of miriam of cults violin
district worldwide
and then it's me if you get out of dilemma laws
probably collectives are
unfinished militants in this
center activism in beige and better caracas
grand bay de cortes platas
because we have to defend this
revolutionary process because with everything that is
being lived right now all that
political trick that the oligarchy has all
that blockade  economic situation that these
Venezuelan businessmen have by hiding the
food, taking the dollars,
taking the Venezuelan currency to
other countries, we are the ones called
to radically defend this process without
hesitation,
and we, the groups, are that
fundamental tool to continue this
fight
and today with this project  What is
Comandante Nicolás Maduro taking out, which
is the anti-coup commando? We are
going to carry it out and we are going to continue
advancing to continue defending this
legacy.
from the
homeland where chávez shaped his entire
revolutionary project until 2000
always as we always say
first the gangster polifreites bag to
more than 200 gration
of higher rating venezuela is weaker
increased and does not understand the egg football
of the fair flag indeed it is the
host fernando de  tumors 30 and 90
cm
we wanted to understand all this gam  and in
one caracas you are more interested in me
romantic tourist mansion house
I want to imitate the ether
braun songs that vince klein shopping
I don't care about government revolution
nothing political as long as they pay me
that there is rent on the way
it doesn't matter
for ccoo with the  police do
things clearly
we try vans cars it
is my first tour and if we see ok
we work on behalf
of the government they send us it
depends on the payment of the person
we cannot verified sex slave can
make exclusion groups and full they
can contradict the man admits
facebook final is  the new facebook
commented
venezuela is not good the world
while andrés campons
before the climate important pressures without
pauses licenses urge
sentimental fiction script 6 this rights of
comedy served lips is include
extradition that lens
my life lamb has been sown in the
town
these are the  tombs gifts
is also all the others
one day they gave us the news of what
and it will be a  DNA tested and they didn't hand over
his body without even being able to see each other
physically we'll see each other through photos which was
the only way we saw them identical he
feared he's all a rotated like
they've endured him in his art
saleh that devours him
that they tortured him
of action and having the being of total dixinn weinstein
and his laws for a thousand lives
james with the effect of venezuela of every
meter multilingualism
international outrage the darkness officials
because the constitutional one already on the side and fran
walsh mature
reuters / law of limits version of
phases
and in  collective
fort and their assistants quiet session said
henrique capriles a public holding company
dealt a blow to the constitution the
constitution was thrown aside and
we entered a stage in my opinion
completely unknown uncertain
marshes uncertainty for us
venezuelans because the majority of
venezuelans  we were born in a democracy and
we can now say clearly that
there is no democracy in venezuela i have
many  fear that venezuela will become
a failed state the formalization of the
country
somalia and 6 in venezuela is the barça
chaves green distribution the 32 chavez social centers it
was seen that the connection between the
president town was maintained now the connection between
the president town has been broken it feels
as if there were a state terrorism
that the state terrorizes so that
people do not express their discontent
james cut com and people on you to the
rings of sciences
I think that we ourselves as a people
should seek the solution because
we are the power and if
we went out to the streets to look for a new
solution to change the president we
can achieve it
wisin y yandel
and more your blog
that's why
if we have to give up our lives for this
revolutionary process that's why we were
called
[Music]